so i want to tell you about a letter
i got a little while ago that i only
just got around to reading
[Music]
actually it was in 2003 that it arrived
but i only just found it on the floor my
study is very messy
so the author is a contributor to the
oais
a former contributor i have how you
think i have to say
called claude lenomo he suggested two
transformations of sequences
his second transformation that
introduced a word
i didn't know in a french word called
um lebeau this is a rebel
a player carpenter's plane and his
transformation
is to take a sequence or a word
a string of numbers and playing them
down
or about a planing the sequence
what you plane down are the runs in a
sequence
if we have a sequence you might be
tossing a coin and you might get heads
heads tails tails tails heads
tails you look at the runs here we've
got a run of two heads
so we get a two we write down the length
of the runs
three one one so the runs transformation
of a string a sequence is the lengths of
the runs
that's the runs transformation what the
the plane does
it shortens all the runs by one by one
turn
so if we had a run of three things in
the transform
thing we've got a run of two things so
we shorten all the runs
that's the operation of rapote so you
remember in one of the
earlier number file videos you did you
mentioned
a sequence of my old friend sol galam
and this is distinguished by the fact
that
it's a sequence of numbers it's the
as the property that there it's an
increasingly i should say non-decreasing
sequence it keeps
growing and it has the property
that if you look at the runs length you
get the same sequence
all right i'll just do a couple of terms
one two
two how do we continue golem sequence
the one means the first run has length
one
so we start off with a run of length one
and then we've got a run
of some other numbers and you always
pick the smallest number
so the next number has to be a two that
two
says the second run has length two
so we've got two twos and now that two
which is the third term says the third
run
has length two so so yeah so it
continues three three
and then four four four five five five
this will probably make it clearer
so this two refers to those two the
third term
is two and that says the third run
of successive identical terms has length
two
well okay we've got our first run our
second run
our third run has to have length two so
that means we've got two threes
the fourth term and that says the next
run has length three
so there are going to be three fours
that three says
three fours this three says aha
three five so there'll be four sixes
there are gonna be four
sixes very good and there are going to
be four sevens
from that four and that four says there
are going to be four eights
and that five says there are going to be
five nines
that's the defining property it's
non-decreasing
you always put down the smallest number
you can
and it must be its own runs
transformation so that's column sequence
now if we apply the rubber to it
and we plane it down what are we going
to do well
we're going to cross off that one we've
got two twos
so we throw away one of them we've got
two threes we throw away one of them
we've got three fours we throw away one
five we just
shorten all the runs we apply
the plane the rebel and what we get
the new sequence is simply
two three four four five
five six six six seven
seven seven and so on so this is the
plain down version
of golem sequence in
claude's letter he gave the example of
the
golem sequence and how to rubate it
so i thought it would be very
interesting to apply
the plain la rabo to the numbers
to the ordinary numbers written in
binary
now remember the rule is when you plane
it down
if it's got a run of length one it goes
away so zero
well becomes zero so we get zero
one goes away and we get zero
one goes away zero goes away and we get
zero one one
becomes one in base
2 which is 1 in base 10. so our new
sequence
is what you get when you plane down the
numbers so we get 0 0 0
this is the base 2 version this is the
base 10 version
so one note naught we lose the
one and we shorten that zero and we get
zero
one zero one zero base two is zero base
ten say
here now finally we get something
interesting we lose the zero
and we lose a 1 so we get 1.
here 1 1 1 we lose the 1 we got 1 1
which is 1 1 which is 3. so the sequence
that we're going to get goes 0 0 0 1 0 0
1 three this one we lose that
and that and we get zero this we lose
the one
and that and we get zero and ten
we lose everything and
eleven we lose that that and that and we
get one
twelve we lose a one and a zero and
finally
we get a two we're doing thirteen we
lose
that and that and that and we get a one
because 12 is one one zero zero it
becomes
one zero which is two thirteen which is
one one zero one
we lose the one the zero and one of the
ones and all we are left with
is a one when we get to 14
we lose a zero and a one and we're left
with one one which
is three and one one one one which is
fifteen
we lose the one we get one one one and
we get seven and when we get down to 16
we get zero again so that's and we keep
going forever
so this is the plane down version
this has a very nice sound you know you
can listen to any
any of the 300 000 sequences in the oeis
and i would like to play this sequence
for you
[Music]
[Music]
how have you turned into music we
imagine that we have a grand piano
that's the basic thing and we number the
keys
0 1 2 3 up to 87
it's got 88 keys we take the number
and we divide by 88 and keep the
remainder we
reduce it mod 88 so that gives us
something we can play on the grand piano
so if they're
these numbers you can see they're all
pretty small so it stays down
here at the bottom of the keyboard for
quite a long time until we get up to
some very big numbers before we actually
have to round them down
why do you like that piece of music yeah
why do i like it well
it has that rhythm to it it goes da da
da da da da
and those those repetitions are because
of the binary expansion
and then every so often like at fifty
pounds of two minus one we get a bigger
number
and before it we get some other big
numbers so there's a rhythm
so the sound the sounds
reflect the structure of the binary
numbers
but processed is not just the straight
binary numbers
[Music]
neil as you keep planing the binaries
obviously we were we were staying pretty
low though with those numbers
do you start eventually getting some big
numbers when you turn them into you know
base 10
yeah certainly when we got up to say 2
to the 20 minus 1
playing off one we get 19 ones in a row
so eventually we get all does every
number appear here sure
okay so there's an inverse operation
which is extending all the runs by one
bit
and that works for any number what's
that called if that's if that's
what do you call the other version i
just called it expanding
claude didn't mention it in his letter
but obviously you could do it
you expand all the runs by one and then
if you applied his operation
you'd get back to where you started so
you can get every number
so a question is after you've planed
down a number
how big is it what's the average value
after you plane it down so i looked at
that and
i asked some friends for help and they
proved my conjecture is correct
if n is k bits
long in binary in other words if it's
the k bit number
so for instance here are all the three
bit numbers
there are actually four of them a three
bit number
beginning with one of course apart from
zero every
binary number begins with one so we
could have one naught naught all the way
up to one one one
so there are um two to the k minus one
three bit numbers there are two squared
numbers there are four of them what's
the average value
well it happens to be we had four
numbers
um whose sum is four so the average
value afterwards is one
so what happens for a k bit number i
conjectured
that the average value after is
exactly three halves to the power k
minus
two minus a half and the way i found
that was i worked out the average
you can see i just worked out the
average for three bit numbers and i got
one if you do that for the first 20 or
30
terms you get a sequence what you do
when you get a sequence you look it up
in the oais
and it is sequence a 27649
which is the integer three halves to the
k minus one minus a half
so the answer to this question how big
is what you get
it's about three halves to the k
so n was about two to the k and we
shrunk it down
to three halves to the k so that's the
answer
you might remember these pieces of pie
we shared with number five supporters a
while back
well they were so popular we've now
created these unique views
of our beloved mandelbrot set each piece
is individually numbered and is a
one-off perspective
a different location a different
magnification if you'd like us to send
you one
find out more in the link we've included
below
i want to talk about approximating pi in
the mandelbrot set
maybe it's best to do a little bit of a
reminder about what the mandelbrot set
is
so remember the mandelbrot set was this
object that we have in the complex plane
so here are the real numbers and here
imaginary numbers and the mandelbrot set
was
a collection of complex numbers so i'll
try and sort of draw a nice version of
this here